How long do the rife machine bulbs last? Do they burn out?
The rife machine bulbs don't burn out.
So it's not a, it's a gas filled tube.
So there's nothing to burn out as it could desert light bulb or something like that.
So they don't burn out.
However, they can, you know, they can break.
You can drop the bulb. Typically, if you dropped it just down flat on itself,
it's not going to break. It's encased in plastic.
But if you drop it on the end, so those, those electrical cords go into the tube
and they attach through the glass cylinder in there and that can break.
The glass inside there can break.
So if you banged the end of it onto the side of the banner,
if you dropped it down where the cylinder is going straight down
and it hit on the end of the tube that can break and then it's broken.
So that is then going to have to be replaced.
The other thing that we've seen with some of the bulbs over time,
especially the older bulbs.
I mean, people that have had them for several years,
it can start the cords themselves because it's, you know, electricity going through those cords,
especially on the older true right bulbs where they were, where they,
the cords curled around and then were zip tied to the, to the plastic tube.
You need that, that, that, that burn into the plastic casing of the,
of the cord, the cord has just gone bad and you can't replace that.
So the whole bulb just has to be replaced.
We had, we had several of those actually in the last couple of months
where people said there's felt, they smelled, smell coming from that
and then they noticed the cord was getting really hot.
If that's the case, you're going to have to replace the tube.
So the, there's nothing else you could do about that.
What else can you do to damage the cords on the bulbs?
So of course you can break the bulb if you really hit it hard.
You can break the end of the bulb so you look at it.
You can't see any damage because that is on the end, like I said,
if you dropped it on the edge and you hit it at just right,
you could, you could snap the glass in there and all the gas would leak out of the tube
and you notice it doesn't work.
It doesn't light up at all anymore.
We've had that happen a couple of times and then you could burn,
the cord could burn and that has to be replaced.
The other thing is the ends of the cord where it plugs into the knife machine,
especially if you yank on them and don't grab the red or the black
and carefully, gently wiggle it out.
If you yank on it or lots of times it's happening where somebody trips
on the cord and it pulls it out and that can damage that piece
and then that, that could typically be repaired.
Nothing else can be repaired.
So yeah, so understand our warranty on the bulbs is nonexistent.
So if something happens to it, it's user error.
So you're going to have to cover the cost of that repair.
I mean, if it's a repair on the end of it, it's not such a big deal.
But if anything else, you just have to replace the bulb.
So if the bulb comes to you and it works and then something happens
and it doesn't work, then unfortunately that's going to be on you
to replace that bulb.